[Music]
on this Monday night an Ontario group
home operator under scrutiny there's
nothing you can do legally to stop them
so what are you supposed to do the kids
and teens desperate to escape a
dangerous situation Global News
investigates
the advice the head of Canada's spy
agency gave the Prime Minister about
invoking the emergencies act it was
indeed required and remember saying that
yes New Revelations at the inquiry
mixing politics with sports the goal to
stand up for human rights at the World
Cup and moon Milestone you are seeing
the Earth you are seeing home another
success for NASA's Artemis mission
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us for
more than a year our investigative team
has been uncovering harrowing details
about Ontario's child welfare system
tonight an examination into a for-profit
company that runs group homes and Foster
homes for kids who have been abused
orphaned or have behavioral issues homes
where kids were so desperate to escape
they risk falling into a world of drugs
and sex trafficking Carolyn Jarvis hears
our top story tonight in a warning some
of the images in it may be disturbing
wow
what you're hearing are the cries of an
11 year old girl being physically
restrained by group home workers
in the Next Room Cassidy Frank would
listen to this sometimes for hours
they'd restrain her everywhere on the
bed on the floor against the wall
Cassidy was one of four girls who in
2021 lived together in this group home a
place for kids who've been abused
orphaned or have behavioral issues
the home is run by a for-profit company
called hats off one of the largest
operators of group homes in Ontario
here Cassidy says her trauma only
deepened it was scary really really
scary which is why when a worker at the
home named shadia Youssef offered to be
a mother figure to Cassidy and take her
home she saw a way out
I'm Cassidy's new mother
so nobody verified where you were going
no Yusuf took her to her apartment and
on the first day Cassidy says forced her
to sell drugs
she's like get out of the car and go
sell it incredibly the worker who was
supposed to protect her overdosed
Cassidy says and police took her to
hospital
meanwhile Cassidy was left alone in the
apartment for two weeks as strange men
came to check on her she says warning
she was at risk of being trafficked I
was freaking out I was like okay like
what do I do Yusuf denies any connection
to drugs or human trafficking and says
she left because she had a breakdown
the vulnerable use in group homes should
be nowhere near drugs or human
trafficking but they are often
dangerously interwoven group homes in
residential treatment centers are
magnets for exploiters former hats off
workers whose identities we've concealed
for fear of reprisal say girls as young
as 12 would leave in the middle of the
night when they would come back they
would report it was with these strangers
they made me do weird things like
consume illicit substances they would
engage in sexual acts
a lot of Youth would disclose I was just
so desperate to get out of here in hats
off group homes workers say there was no
money for outings and Ministry
inspection show for a time one home
relied on a Food donation from a church
look at it crawl workers documented bed
bugs and infestation in a basement
rats and severe disrepair dismal living
conditions that hats off says have been
resolved it also disputes the rat
complaint and a lack of money for kids
you want things right hats off doesn't
value anything the pimp will give them
the love that they want and every other
thing they want but what makes hats off
Stand Out is just how many kids ran away
in four years hatsoff reported kids
going AWOL as they call it
1170 times among the highest per bed of
any group home operator in the province
there's nothing you can do legally to
stop them so what are you supposed to do
hats off which declined an interview
said missing kid reports are filed for
many reasons including being late for
curfew
though it acknowledged human trafficking
victims often played a role it has
undertaken a massive effort to train
staff at said and developed safety plans
it also said restraints are used as a
last Intervention when the safety of a
child is at immediate risk
as for Cassidy a knock on the apartment
door was her salvation undercover
officers with the human trafficking unit
slipped through a fake business card
with their number on it when she was
alone she made the call and police
officers drove her seven hours North to
be reunited with her mother
shadia Youssef was never charged
the group home Cassidy fled was closed
shortly after she left though hats off
still operates nine others what does the
government need to know about hats off
shut it down
after our deadline we received an email
with 40 letters of endorsement from hats
off workers at the request of their CEO
while approximately half of them were
Anonymous they described a family-like
environment where staff go the extra
mile money isn't an issue and the homes
are well cared for certainly a
dramatically different perspective from
the roughly 70 people we spoke with for
our investigation
Donna all right Carolyn Jarvis thanks
and the investigation continues tomorrow
allegations of over-medicating kids at
hats off group homes and what the
Ontario government has to say about our
findings now to some revealing testimony
at the inquiry into the use of the
federal emergencies act last February
the head of cesus the Canadian Security
intelligence service says he advised the
prime minister to invoke the act in
order to end the protests that occupied
the streets near Parliament Hill for
weeks at issue in these hearings is
whether invoking the Act was warranted
the head of cesa said even though the
protests didn't meet the legal
definition of a national security threat
according to the rules of his
organization he did think invoking the
emergencies Act was necessary Mike
Armstrong explains good morning and this
was the third time the top officials
with Canada spy agency have spoken to
the commission but the first time
publicly the other hearings were behind
closed doors to keep classified
information Secret we're not
investigating the Convoy itself the head
of thesis was careful to lay out why the
spy agency was involved in something
that wasn't related to espionage or
foreign interference public protest is
protected he said but there were
individuals taking part who cesus was
already watching the spy agency kept an
eye on them and the possibility they
could spread violent extremism so it was
essentially a two-fold analysis making
sure we understood what our subject and
investigations were doing associating
with and so on but also understanding
who were others who could potentially
radicalize
now under cesus's mandate the head of
the spy agency said the so-called
Freedom Convoy never fit its definition
of a threat to the security of Canada
but David Vino was part of cabinet
meetings where use of the emergency Act
was debated he told the commission
Monday that in those meetings he told
the Prime Minister the ACT should be
invoked that its definition of a threat
was different from that of cesus that
opinion was provided if you want as a
national security advisor as opposed to
a the director of csis specifically 10
13 a.m now there was some friction
between the ceases panel and the lawyer
for the protesters he was trying to
argue the people with confederate and
Nazi flags were plants to make the
protesters look bad even going so far as
naming an employee at a public relations
firm the council I have not have not
testified to that Council yeah you
haven't testified to it but you know
that to be true don't you
no that's not fair firstly the statement
the company calls the accusation absurd
and Despicable and says it's reviewing
legal options the police services have
also on the stand Monday emergency
preparedness Minister Bill Blair he is
the first of seven cabinet ministers
expected to take the stand this week
Justin Trudeau is scheduled to appear
Friday Donna all right Mike Armstrong in
Ottawa thanks in Colorado there is
heartbreak at outrage after the shooting
at an lgbtq nightclub Saturday night
five people were killed at least 20
others injured and it could have been
worse some of the patrons are being
hailed as Heroes for stopping the gunman
the 22 year old suspect faces five
counts of first-degree murder and bias
motivated crime causing injury his
background is still being investigated
but police say he has a history of
violence Jennifer Johnson reports
as a makeshift Memorial grows outside
Colorado Springs Club Q a community and
mourning wants answers why the shooter
picked that nightclub known as a safe
haven for the City's lgbtq community and
should Colorado's red flag law been
triggered to potentially stop the
shooter from getting Firearms it's still
too early and I hate to say that because
people want information at this stage uh
you know the the people people deserve
to know what happened here many are
wondering how accused shooter 22 year
old Anderson Lee Aldridge got the AR-15
style semi-automatic weapon used in the
shootings blow it to holy hell after
videos obtained by the Associated Press
show a standoff Aldrich had with police
in 2021 live streaming himself on
Facebook as he threatened to blow up his
mother's home family members who lost
loved ones in Saturday night's deadly
shooting are in Shock it's just a
nightmare that you can't wake up from
I keep thinking it's so you know it's
just it's a mistake they've made a
mistake and that he's really alive
officials are investigating whether this
was a hate crime officials say Aldrich
immediately opened fire after entering
the club but instead of running for
their lives two patrons struggled with
the shooter hit him with his own gun and
tackled him to the ground I don't know
who stopped him but I'm grateful because
they most certainly saved my life police
say those patrons likely saved many
lives
the nightclub Massacre has sparked
vigils in cities across the country and
more fear among the lgbtq community
there's always going to be people that
just hate that I exist for no real
reason last year anti-gay crimes in the
U.S surged by more than 50 percent now
this community is its latest victim
trying to heal from this horrific mass
shooting
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
the union representing hundreds of lobla
workers in Calgary says more than 534
members have been given layoff notices
the union says that amounts to 99
percent of workers at the loblood
Distribution Center contract
negotiations are underway workers are
asking for a wage increase the union
says it's prepared to restart talks to
avoid further layoffs Global News
reached out to Loblaw for comment last
week the company reported a 30 percent
increase in its third quarter profits
compared to last year
warnings to stop it now or else coming
up renewed fears of Europe's largest
nuclear power plant being in the
crosshairs of Russia's war in Ukraine
Rescuers in Indonesia are working to
save people trapped after a powerful
earthquake hit the main island of java
at least 162 people are known to have
died hundreds more are injured and
overwhelmed hospitals are treating them
outside on stretchers and blankets the
magnitude 5.6 Quake struck the greater
Jakarta area in the late afternoon
Indonesian officials say more than 13
thousand people were displaced by the
disaster which damaged thousands of
homes Indonesia is on the Pacific Ring
of Fire the most seismically active Zone
in the world the number of dead is
expected to rise as rescue teams reach
rural areas
winter is coming fast in Ukraine and now
people who are already suffering because
of Russia's attacks are having to leave
their homes authorities have begun
evacuations from Recently liberated
regions because there's no heat power or
water the World Health Organization
warns millions are facing a
life-threatening winter
the devastating energy crisis the
deepening Mental Health Emergency
constraints on humanitarian access and
the risk of viral infections
will make this winter a formidable test
for the Ukraine health system and the
Ukraine people
there are also Stark warnings tonight
about a potential nuclear disaster at
the Zappa region nuclear power plant our
Europe bureau chief Crystal gomancing
Reports
images of the damage have not been
shared but the international atomic
energy agency which has monitors inside
the Ukrainian nuclear plant says a
radioactive waste and storage building
cooling Pond sprinkler system and a
cable for one of the diesel backup
generators have all been affected until
we have this plant protected the
possibility of a nuclear catastrophe is
there Rafael Grossi the director general
of the iaea told 60 Minutes the
zeparizio power plant's position on the
front lines of the war creates an
unprecedented situation for the world
Rosie has met personally with the
presidents of both Russia and Ukraine
imploring both men to create a buffer
zone around the facility the plant is
occupied by Russian forces strikes this
past weekend according to a statement
put out by the Watchdog agency came
within meters of Key Safety and Security
Systems if you protect it there's no
Dairy bump
while the world has so far avoided a
nuclear disaster shelling around
zephyrizio region has resulted in heaps
of pain
with my own eyes I saw glass flying
shrapnel flying drawers falling on me
seconds later there was a fire the gas
line erupted
says he was barefoot walking through the
debris to rescue his mother-in-law
all of this on a day of reflection in
Ukraine November 21st marks the maidan
uprising
the deadly three-month-long Civil War
started in 2013 when the government
unexpectedly ditched a European Union
agreement opting to strengthen ties with
Russia the people eventually secured new
elections constitutional reforms and got
that EU Association lighting the fuse on
the Powder Keg between the Kremlin and
Ukraine
Crystal gomancing Global News London
relations between two Balkan neighbors
Kosovo and Serbia are deteriorating
rapidly and a dispute over vehicle
license plates is prompting warnings of
a possible return to the Region's
violent past the European Union's top
Diplomat spent eight hours today urging
leaders of Serbia and Kosovo to
de-escalate he says both parties showed
unconstructive Behavior the flashpoint
is a demand 10 000 costs of inserves to
replace their Serbian license plates
with ones from Kosovo or face stiff
fines in response more than 600 costs of
unserved police officers resigned about
thirteen thousand people died in the war
for kosovo's independence which began in
1998 Serbia launched a brutal Crackdown
to curb a separatist Rebellion by ethnic
albanians NATO bombed Serbia in 1999 to
end the war and Kosovo declared
independence but Serbia doesn't
recognize it
Qatar controversy ahead what is
overshadowing the soccer matches
[Music]
the World Cup is supposed to be all
about soccer but in Qatar it was always
going to be more complicated from
allegations of corruption to the fact
homosexuality is illegal there there's a
great deal overshadowing the matches
Canada's first game is on Wednesday
Today International Development Minister
harjit sajan met Canada's team part of a
diplomatic visit to Qatar some human
rights campaigners are disappointed the
Canadian government didn't boycott the
tournament like it did the Beijing
Olympics Redmond Shannon reports on how
politics and soccer are clashing at this
world cup
yeah take it chaos the app stop working
not what you'd expect from an event
estimated to have cost more than 100
billion dollars many fans missed the
start of the England Iran game including
its political dance England's Captain
Harry Kane wanted to wear this rainbow
armband in support of lgbtq2 plus rights
in Qatar it came after FIFA's president
bizarrely said on Saturday today I feel
uh gay on Monday FIFA threatened Kane
and six other European captains with
yellow cards unless they wore these FIFA
armbands instead so the teams backed
down it's a shame that it's it's it's
not happening because it's uh it's just
a fight against discrimination all
around the world but England's players
did take a knee to highlight inequality
and Iran's team refused to sing their
Anthem a gesture apparently in support
of women's rights protesters back home
Canada's Minister for International
Development harjit John is in Qatar he
met with some of the Canadian team
before he watches the long-awaited
opener Wednesday human rights
campaigners want Team Canada to follow
the lead of other nations and take a
stand in support of Migrant workers
rights and other oppressed groups in
Qatar I hope that the Canadian
delegation the official delegation will
use this opportunity to highlight to the
team that this is a Canadian priority
Canada Soccer is not saying whether
anything is planned sajan meets Cutters
Deputy Prime Minister Tuesday sajan
spokesperson told global news that
Canada will continue to engage Qatar
bilaterally on key Canadian priorities
including human rights I don't
anticipate that there's any real
authenticity to the message that they're
going to give around legislative reforms
some lgbtq2 plus Advocates think
Canada's government should have
boycotted Qatar altogether weather like
it did with this year's Beijing Winter
Games Redmond Shannon Global News London
[Music]
surround the far
[Music]
we are now less than two minutes away
from our anticipated loss of signal as
Orion travels behind the Moon
Orion is doing its thing leaving NASA in
the dark for 34 minutes as it whipped
around The Far Side of the Moon at one
point it was about 130 kilometers from
the surface of the Moon this test flight
is unmanned but as Eric Sorensen reports
if all goes well it is the first step in
a new era of lunar exploration
as the Orion spacecraft pulled away from
Earth five days ago it set its sights on
the moon now 370 thousand kilometers
away the images evoke a sense of wonder
even from NASA officials looking back
home now you are seeing the Earth you
are seeing home you are seeing yourself
in that image right there as Orion
disappeared Behind The Far Side of the
Moon in this animation flying just over
100 kilometers above the surface Mission
Control lost contact as expected for an
anxious 30 minutes and then relief as
our planet re-emerged the Artemis
Mission still on course our pale blue
dot and it's 8 billion human inhabitants
now coming into view
[Music]
it's been 50 years since NASA sent a
spacecraft with astronauts to the moon
and back there is additional caution now
this flight is carrying test dummies
moonachins part of a rigorous testing
that will see the spacecraft swing into
a much more distant orbit before making
its return we're going to be going 40
000 miles past the moon getting into
deep space analyzing all the data from
the Anthony metric dummies on board
looking at the radiation environment and
making sure that it performs as it
should before we put crew on board the
Orion spacecraft that crew is scheduled
to be on board in just two years and
will include one of four active Canadian
astronauts in a few months we should
hear which Canadian that will be it
would be announced students following
concerning the crew that will be on
board the Artemis too among which
Canadian space agency astronaut in as
little as three years astronauts are
expected to return to the surface of the
Moon that will begin a new era not just
to visit the moon and ultimately Mars
but to establish a lunar base where
humans will learn to work and to live in
another world Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
and that's global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's here
Canada is snowy Calgary Alberta we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]